our eight news now investigators
obtaining exclusive photos of a reported
Act of terrorism at a solar facility in
north of Las Vegas that facility
providing clean energy to us right here
in the valley and thank you for joining
us at six I'm Brian Loftus and I'm
Denise Valdez police say this incident
took that massive facility offline eight
news now investigator David charns with
the exclusive photos tonight David Brian
Denise with recent incidents at Power
generating facilities all across our
country you can understand why Metro
Police and the FBI took this so
seriously we've confirmed this man from
Idaho was in town for New Year's now
he's not leaving anytime soon as he's
facing terror-related charges
photos theaters now investigators
obtained show the burnt car police
suspect a man set on fire inside a Las
Vegas area solar facility the giant
array producing energy for MGM
generating power for its strip
properties police believe 34-year-old
Muhammad mesmarian seen in these
surveillance images ran the car through
the gates at the plant Tuesday afternoon
around midnight Wednesday Ms Marion
allegedly drove that car into this pit
siphoning gasoline onto wires and
setting the vehicle on fire police say
Ms Marion then sat in a chair watching
the car burn detectives believed
mesmarian was scoping the site for at
least a day a nearby business calling
police saying a man later identified as
mesmarion was trespassing officer same
as Marion reportedly told them he was
born in Iran Works odd jobs and was in
town with his mother on Thursday a day
now after the fire at the facility
police found mesmarian out of Boulder
Beach Campground around and took him
into custody they say he attempted to
run away from them twice
[Music]
Ms Marion was reportedly disruptive
before his first court hearing Friday
and did not appear the judge ordering
him held without bail
now according to those documents the
fire caused some major damage to one
unit there taking this entire facility
offline again that is according to
police a spokesperson for the company
that runs this plant says they are
working to get it back online I'm David
charns 8 news now and David a final note
here miss Marion is due in court again
next week no MGM property nor the power
grid were impacted